你要给自己留一条后路，
为什么呢？
你这俩孩子一定跟你很有缘分吗？
一定很听你的话吗？
一定很感恩你吗？
都未必，
我怕就怕你到时候呀，
不结婚不生孩子，
这俩孩子到时候养出白眼狼了，
什么都理所当然了，
什么都觉得你该为他们付出了，
你这辈子你就真的挺亏的。
我现在想问一下，
如果就是收养小孩的话，
需要什么手续啊，
收养小孩啊，
你现在是已婚状态吗？
我未婚，
你现在多大年纪30，
如果你收养同性别的孩子应该是可以的，
但是你收养不了小男孩孩，
我大概跟你说一下什么情况吧，
我本身是小时候，
现在属于那种留守儿童，
是外公外婆带他跟我一起长大的，
还有表哥啊表姐啊什么的，
结果就前几天嘛，
我表哥他们那个意外走掉了，
走掉了之后呢，
这两个小孩在我家这边已经住了有一段时间了，
我爸妈是觉得他那个挺可怜的嘛，
至少待在这里的话，
有一口吃的，
在这里突然间出了这么个事情之后，
那小孩子他还能活下去对不对？
父母都不在了，
在我表哥他那个小时候，
他爸妈就几乎是都已经分开了的状态，
该嫁的也嫁了，
该娶的也娶了，
现在的话，
两个老人吧，
至少有个60岁的，
因为我跟他。
们也不太熟，
他们的抚养能力肯定是也没有，
他们自己生小孩儿，
现在小孩儿也都在上学，
如果这两个孩子过去的话，
别的不说，
我感觉估计连吃都吃不饱，
我就想咨询一下，
如果这种情况我们要收养他的话，
就是需要提供些什么东西，
是亲表哥吗？
对是吧，
就是我妈妈哥哥家的儿子，
那你现在是没有结婚的状态吗？
我是没有结婚，
如果你是这个状态的话，
我给你一个建议，
就是不要办收养，
就是帮助拉扯，
为什么呢？
你一旦办了收养了之后，
像你这个情况是可能，
嗯，
能突破这个40岁的这样一个要求，
因为他是近亲属之间的，
相当于是过继的收养，
他的条件会宽很多，
你能办收养，
但我不建议你办收养，
原因是什么？
原因是你将来还要组建自己的家庭，
你会有自己的孩子，
你会有自己的老公，
你办了这个收养，
在法律上就是一视同仁的，
但是实际上你是不可能做到一视同仁的，
只要你有自己亲生的孩子，
你作为人性，
作为母性，
你就会把资源偏向自己亲生的孩子。
你不可能说我有300万的遗产，
我这三个孩子平分吧，
不可能你一定会说我这孩子分250万吧，
剩下的给你俩一点是个意思，
理解了吧，
你不断收养的话，
你对他们永远是姑姑是姨，
孩子对姑姑和姨不会生出一种公平对待的心，
他不会要求我。
姑姑和姨要求对待他亲生儿子和对待我是一样的，
不会要求说姑姑和姨留遗产的时候给我们留一样的理解了吧，
你会降低两个孩子的心理预期，
反而有可能生出感恩之心，
但一旦你办了收养，
而你将来你又结婚，
你又再生孩子，
你对待孩子又不可能一碗水端平，
你反而会养出两个白眼狼，
明白吧，
你就有钱，
有这个时间，
有这个精力，
你就养在身边，
他就该感恩你。
我大概跟你说一下为什么想给他们收养的原因吧。
我表哥呢，
他是一直反正从小到大父母也没管过的类型，
她长大了之后，
自己存了钱，
自己娶老婆，
自己养个小孩，
也养的挺好的。
但是那个女的呢，
孩子她也不在，
就乎知道每天就是在直播里面，
就是跟各种各样的人聊一些，
那些有的没的，
一年前就开始在闹离婚嘛，
很过分的，
我听他们说的时候是躺在他旁边跟别人打的，
视频睡觉，
这种事情都能发生，
然后后面就变成了这个跟你为什么要收养这两个孩子有什么关系呢？
他妈妈是因为他爸爸去世的，
他爸爸也知道了我们为什么想收养，
这是觉得孙小亮的话，
他年纪上，
他的父母更改了以后上学什么的，
没有人再去说他们这些上学的时候，
只要不在当地去上学，
换个地方上学，
没有什么大不了的，
就是说这俩孩子的亲生父亲。
前是车祸死的，
这俩孩子的亲生妈妈，
现在是怎么回事儿，
他妈妈是被他爸爸给没杀了，
他爸爸把他妈妈了，
然后他爸爸了，
是不是把他俩换个环境读书，
不要在当地读书，
哪怕换个隔壁的县城读书，
换个隔壁的镇读书，
不要在当地读书，
不要受这个影响就行了，
就换个地方读书，
人家在问哎，
爸爸妈妈怎么样，
双双去世怎么去世的，
意外去世完事儿，
没有人会查你在学校里面没有人会查你爸妈是怎么的，
现在的话，
我本身从小嘛，
我们那边就比较重男轻女嘛，
从小反正父母的什么的爱啊着没感受过，
然后你说对婚姻这这些东西，
其实这么多年吧，
我觉得脱贫比脱单重要多了，
所以我一直在不停的努力工作啊，
干嘛的，
现在的话已经到这个年纪了，
其实也无所谓房子车子什么的，
我在外地，
我也蛮好的，
你如果真的养他们的话，
养了之后结婚这种事情也不会在意，
撑死了也就是谈谈男朋友什么的，
我觉得应该也不会允许他俩这个孩子多大，
几岁到几岁，
一个是9岁，
一个是6岁，
姐妹你要相信龙菲姐的判断好不好？
龙菲姐的判断是你要给自己留一条后路，
为什么呢？
你这俩孩子一定跟你很有缘分吗？
一定很听你的话吗？
一定很感恩你吗？
都未必，
我怕，
就怕你到时候你俩不结婚，
不生孩子，
这俩孩子到时候。
长出白眼狼了，
什么都理所当然了，
什么都觉得你该为他们付出了，
你这辈子你就真的挺亏的，
那我问一下，
我现在因为他两个小孩还在我家里面住着的嘛，
如果我们不接受这个小孩儿的话，
我们需要去起诉他爷爷奶奶呢，
还是怎么做后呢？
因为他现在没有人来，
这两个孩子有没有人要，
没有人要你就带在身边养就好了，
给饭吃就好了，
给地方住就好了，
给买衣服就好了，
给他们上学就好了，
不需要跟爷爷奶奶打什么官司的，
他们两个人只要有户口本，
只要有身份证，
上学没问题的呀，
爸妈都了呀，
作为一个姑姑，
给他们报名或者要交钱就好了呀，
我们可以就是先打电话让他爷爷奶奶履行这个职责，
我们帮一下吗？
他们真的拒绝之后，
我们再养吗？
还是他爷爷奶奶有这个能力养吗？
没有的话，
你们可以让当地的村委会，
当地的居委会，
当地的妇联坐下来，
让他们参与签个协议，
就相当于是把监护权委托给你。
法律上有这样的做法，
就是当爷爷奶奶法律上有监护权，
但是爷爷奶奶没有这个监护能力的时候，
他可以把这个监护权委托给你的，
他父母留下的债务的话，
我们不用承担吧，
不要承担，
如果孩子存在，
他也不会往孩子身上去，
生死债难倾尽去啊，
姑娘啊，
别到时候你一颗善心付出了一辈子，
到时候自己啥也没捞着，
那就不。
完算了啊，
是的，
因为我爸妈也不太懂，
他们其实一开始跟我说的是要不然的话问一下律师，
就是能不能起诉他爷爷奶奶，
先让他们就是尝试着，
我家里还有弟弟妹妹，
他们俩呢，
也都未婚，
我自己的亲弟弟他也没结婚，
来事之后我们结了婚也要有孩子，
可以问一下当地的政策，
他们这两个孤儿应该是可以领一些补助的，
这两个孩子他是贵州的户口，
我们现在人是在常州生活，
我们如果要给他申请这些东西的话，
是要回到老家去吗？
那可能是需要，
你可以问一下孤儿的这个补助有多少钱，
有没有这个必要去补助，
就是按照他爷爷奶奶说的，
他是想把他们送到孤儿院去，
但是我妈妈他们就觉得可能如果是真的送过去的话，
已经这么大了嘛，
你现在啥也不懂吧，
她都懂了，
你说啥都懂吧，
也还有点小，
真的送走了可能也太狠，
如果可以的话，
去问一趟也行，
包括孤儿的补助，
包括办低保啊什么的，
能办一点是一点呗，
这个帮他们办的话，
要回到他们的户籍所在地去吧，
应该是这样啊，
刚刚有的人说一人补1000多，
真的吗？
那也挺好的呀，
那也减轻好大负担，
在农村不一定有这么多，
可以先打电话去，
打电话去当地的村支书啊什么的问一下，
而且这个事儿我建议你从头到尾你做介入，
为啥？
这个事儿我也可以作为一个自媒体的素材，
我也可以发出来，
他自己需要。
如果一个姨带着两个表哥的孩子过日子的话，
做自媒体的话，
挺有那个叫什么故事感的，
那倒也我用，
因为我现在上海这边工作的话，
工资还可以，
蛮高的，
就是养他们俩的话，
我算了一下，
一年顶多30了，
就十来万块钱，
所以你用不是姑娘，
有些事儿你不明白，
我给你讲的这个是什么意思呢？
就是说这个故事本身如果能吸引人，
这个确实能给大家带来一些，
比如像你橱窗买点东西支持一下这两个孩子的话，
也是这两个孩子的福报，
也会觉得这俩孩子他自己也参与了这个挣钱的过程，
他也心里也会平衡，
大号都明带来，
谢谢，
好，
就这样啊，
拜拜。
刚刚有朋友说龙飞你是网红，
做很久了，
其实很多人不愿意曝光自己的私人生活的，
哎呀，
我是想到一个姑娘家这两个孩子，
她经济上的支出，
就算这个女孩她再能挣钱，
她经济上的支出的话，
是不是也是很大的负担，
尤其是孩子现在你读个什么书呃，
交个什么学费，
买个什么学习机是吧，
报个什么班儿，
他这个经济负担挺大的，
你以为呢？
当是他不愿意做的是候尊重他啊。
记得点赞关注哦。